the world tonight is in the grip of a  terrible crisis  those unfortunate mistakes of nature are  running wild  could you register her with that mutant  control agency as if she were some sort  of  criminal  this is professor xavier's school for  the gifted all of us here are mutants  like yourself we x-men learn something  very special here jubilee  how to control our mutant powers for the  benefit of mankind  but then why do people hate us  your violence will solve nothing  we must use our special gifts to bring  peace to mankind  if we fail there will be a civil war  better that we die on our feet than live  on our knees  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  you